- I hope to get a hundred percent,
because I love doing well in school,
because I was raised in an environment
which valued learning.
- Me too.
- Yeah, privilege.
- That was so bad.
- So bad.
- Privilege is a very loaded term.
- In a word, is access.
- An advantage that
you're either born with,
or that was handed to you.
- I think it has a lot to do with
how your identity benefits from a system
that has been in place for
a very, very long time.
- Yeah, winning the birth lottery,
to but it bluntly.
(pensive piano music)
- I have no idea how we're
gonna compare to each other.
I'm white, but I'm also Native American.
I'm a man, but I'm also gay.
I'm a Christian, but I'm also poor.
- I think I'm probably
gonna rank pretty low,
as a person of color and as a woman.
- I am a straight, white guy,
went to an Ivy League school,
both parents have graduate degrees.
- And you wear polo tees.
- I feel super privileged,
and I don't know how to talk about it,
which is why I'm forcing
myself to be in this video.
- Being a person of
intersectional identities,
if it's not the Asian side of me,
it's the female side of me,
or the queer side of me.
- I'm a middle class white person,
I expect to very privileged.
- I don't think I'll be
surprised at where I land,
or what you see is not
necessarily what you get with me.
- I think I'd probably
be in the middle upper.
- Maybe in the middle,
as a woman of trans experience,
and as a woman of Asian
American background,
like 50-50.
- I'm excited to play
the oppression Olympics
and see what medal I get.
- USA
- Do you think Donald Trump
got like 1000% on this?
- Woo, this is complicated.
I am a man, because obviously
I identify as a man,
but a man of trans experience.
- I have never been discriminated against
because of my skin color.
I think I have to check this.
- I have never been mocked for my accent.
My family has southern roots,
and I grew up really poor,
so I definitely didn't grow up
speaking the way that I'm speaking now.
- I am not nervous in
airport security lines.
I'm always nervous.
- I've been pulled aside before
where they're like umm, we
see something in like this,
pointing to the junk area.
- See, I've never even thought about
the way trans people
experience airport security.
- Oh, yeah.
- I have lied about my sexuality.
I have had to come out,
and I have doubted my parents'
acceptance of my sexuality,
so huh.
- I fortunately have not had to do that.
- I have never pretended
to be just friends
with my significant other.
- Oof, I have.
- That one just got me.
Having dated women, and also having been
in interracial relationships with men,
I've definitely had those moments.
- I have lied about my religion, I guess.
I feel like I need to take a shower.
- I've never been told I am
attractive for my race.
Does that happen?
- Yeah.
- Oh man.
- I have never felt unsafe
because of my gender,
I have never been catcalled,
I have never been sexually
harassed or assaulted.
Not checking any of those.
- Never been called a fag.
I actually have.
- This question's a slap in the face.
My family and I have never
lived below the poverty line.
Way to just rub it in.
- I don't know how I
expected this to go, but,
uh, it's a lot of check marks.
- I have worked as a waiter, barista,
bartender or salesperson, in fact,
I've worked all four of those jobs.
- I was a barista.
- I worked at my aunt's
restaurant for one weekend.
- I have never attempted suicide.
I've never been depressed.
All that hits a little too close to home.
- Not having student loans is
the thing I feel luckiest about my life.
- Thanks mom and dad.
- Thanks, mom and dad.
- I do not rely on public transportation.
See, you don't think about
public transportation
when you think about privilege.
- I knew that I was privileged,
but this survey is making me think
about a lot of things
that I don't actually
think about on a daily basis.
- I have never lied about my
ethnicity in self-defense.
I absolutely have, and I get away with it
because I'm biracial.
- I consider myself to
be physically attractive.
Is that something that is easy to check?
- I checked that easily.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- I didn't check it.
- Really?
- I consider myself to
be physically attractive.
- Yeah.
- I have never been violently threatened
for my religious beliefs.
I never had, and it immediately made me
like, want to crack, because it's like,
as I speak this sentence,
that's happening to people.
- I was not bullied as a child
for any of my identities.
I mean, yes, I was.
- For what?
- Being smaller.
- Whoo.
- Does anyone have some
joints for after this,
because like, or a good pillow
that I can hold and cry?
- I feel a little sad, all of a sudden,
because there were just so many things
I couldn't check.
- I came into this thinking that
I was pretty privileged,
and I left feeling even more privileged.
- Recognizing your own privilege
is definitely a step
in the right direction.
- Every day I'm obviously very inundated
with the fact that I don't
have a whole lot of privileges,
but I think that I often forget the ones
that I do benefit from.
- It's worth it to look into learning
about the privilege that you have,
because it lets you use it better,
to like, better the lives
of the people around you.
- I encourage everyone to take a look
at their own privilege,
even if you consider yourself to be
someone who is at a disadvantage.
You're probably more
privileged than someone else.
- Going into this test,
the advice that I would give is to
know that it's not gonna
define who you are,
it's not gonna define your character,
and it's not gonna define
your space in life.
Those are things that you can create
on your own, outside of privileges,
it just depends on how you
create a path to get there.